Hello, today is April 11th in the
year 2023.
I'm Karen Herman, and I'm interviewing Joshua
Gay for the Free and Open Source
Stories Digital Archive.
So welcome, Joshua.
Thank you so much for for doing
this.
We're really excited to hear your story.
And I'm going to start right from
from the beginning.
Let me know where and when you
were born.
I was born in just outside of
Boston, a small town, Hingham, Massachusetts in
1981.
And I grew up there, lived lived
there my whole childhood.
I'm one of six kids.
And, yeah.
What did your parents do?
Neither of my parents went to college.
My father had installed flooring and wall
to wall carpentry, his own business.
My mom, most of her career, she
worked as a mortgage officer in a
bank and small banks.
Before that, she, she sort of worked,
you know, sometimes multiple jobs here and
there.
Definitely lower middle class upbringing, but really
great tight knit family, really healthy home,
if not a very small home in
a town with a lot of resources,
and especially towards education and other things
which which made it, you know, just
a really great place to grow up.
What kind of kid would you say
you were?
Oh, I think, you know, I think
I kind of had two sides to
me.
I was maybe a little bit energetic
and get out the house and spend
all day out in the woods and
things like that growing up.
In school, I think I was, you
know, mostly quiet, polite, somewhat reserved.
I've always been extremely curious.
I've never been a very good student
per se.
And in terms of, you know, learning
along with the rest of my class
or in the normal curriculum.
I did really like school, though.
I just didn't necessarily like learning at
the same pace.
So I would often fail and then
and then get excited to learn whatever
it is I failed, and then sort
of catch up and sometimes we jump
ahead and a lot of, you know,
back and forth.
And somehow I managed to make it
all the way through and graduate high
school.
And that trend continued all the way
through high school.
I remember my AP European history teacher
telling me that, and he had been
teaching that course since it started at
my high school.
And he said I was the first
person to fail the course, get an
F in the course, but to pass
the AP exam and get full credit
in college.
And that I think that, you know,
that sort of characterizes a lot of
how I went through school.
I fell behind in middle school, and
then I doubled up and tripled up
sometimes courses in, you know, freshman and
sophomore year in high school in order
to sort of be able to, you
know, continue on a path where I
was engaged and excited.
And yeah, that was really, I think
I was constantly distracted by other things
in life outside of school as well.
And I started working pretty young.
I think my first little job was
in third grade raking leaves.
And I think by fourth grade, I
was delivering newspapers.
And by fifth grade, I was running,
I went from a lemonade stand to
a full concession stand on a golf
course, a public golf course near my
house.
I would just drag out coolers of
things and sell them.
And then after that, I started working
in catering at the same golf course,
a country club events.
And I tend to work around anywhere
from, you know, 15 to 40 hours
a week, even during the school year
and the summers, I would usually have
more than one job.
And so that has continued my entire
life.
I've never stopped working really.
Up until recently, sort of the idea
of just working one job was, I
think it took becoming a parent, where
I said, "oh, that's its own full
time job in a sense that I
can just have one other employer or,
you know, focus area." But definitely throughout
my childhood, I was constantly working in
addition to doing extracurricular activities, and playing
sports and trying.
Did you have any interest in that
at that time?
No, not at all.
I mean, if I had to rank
anything interest, baseball was my number one
interest until I was about 17 or
18.
I developed a strong interest in poetry
around age 14.
In writing it?
In writing it and reading it.
I continue to love to read poetry
and write on my own.
I don't really publish anymore.
I mean, I remember kind of being
intrigued.
In the first moment, I kind of
got intrigued by computer science.
There's TI-82 calculators, what we used or
what I had for school.
And a friend of mine who was
also one of the first people I
knew to run Linux back in the
90s, he introduced me to the world
of programming on a calculator in high
school.
Just started out with little things, you
know, here's a way to just sort
of store notes or to write a
little game, a choose your own adventure
type game.
And then what really got me a
little bit excited was he wrote a
fractal generator and it didn't support imaginary
numbers.
I remember him telling me and I
didn't quite understand what that was because
I didn't really understand fractals at the
time.
But he showed me how he worked
around this and did sort of all
of these things.
And I was like, you just did
that on your calculator.
And it's generating these different pictures and
things like that.
And zooming in.
And I was really kind of captivated
by that idea that you could, you
know, that anybody could just sit there
and write something like that and it
would make it work.
For the most part, my interest in
computers, though, in high school was graphic
design.
One of the things that sort of,
I guess, probably helped me get into
college was I won a regional graphic
design contest.
I didn't, so there was a graphics
arts class and one of the portions
of it was in addition to making
printed things and using the big sort
of industrial printer that we had and
whatnot was learning to use things like
Adobe Photoshop.
I remember I made a, I think,
the Leonardo da Vinci, is it Petruvian
man, is that right?
Sort of in the circle and the
arms and the leg.
I took that and I manipulated it
and did, you know, sort of a
creative project.
And I didn't realize that when I
submitted it that my teacher was going
to go ahead and submit it on
my behalf to this regional contest.
And he did and I happened to
win, which was pretty nice of him
to just go ahead and do that.
And then in 10th or 11th grade,
I taught in an after school program
in our middle school, HTML 1.0.
So I learned how to make web
pages and things when HTML first came
out.
I didn't think of it as programming.
I just thought of it as more
like making, you know, like graphic design,
like, you know, putting together very much
a a front end mentality, right?
I wasn't thinking I'm making computers do
things.
I'm displaying, you know, text and art
and colors.
Did you really learn it yourself?
Did you teach it to yourself?
Yeah, yeah, I did.
I know that we had like a
short media studies thing where we had
like a couple days in the library
where we were introduced to it and
some program that you could use to
make, some early program that you could
use to make a website, some sort
of page maker.
But when I taught the class, I
just had everybody write the HTML.
And so I learned, you know, what
was happening underneath the website and how
to do that.
I don't remember it being anything that
I don't remember the learning part.
It was just, oh, how does this
work?
And then I figured it out.
And so there was always that kind
of desire to tinker, I think.
Yeah.
What did you think you wanted to
be?
What kind of career path were you
thinking when you were in high school?
When I first got in, I had
a goal that I just basically wanted
to be a multimillionaire.
I was working all the time and
I was working on a golf course
when I was in middle school, right,
on my own and being a young
entrepreneur, I was called often.
And there was an investor, sort of
a personal finance person from Smith Barney,
who said, "you should come down to
the office and open up, you know,
an investment account with us." And I
remember doing that in eighth grade.
And I got a reading list of
a book went up on Wall Street
and some other things.
And I was going to be a
value investor like Warren Buffett.
And that was fun.
And I still have, you know, some
investments from that day that are accruing,
which is nice.
But I kind of lost interest in
that by tenth grade.
Poetry and sort of creative work was
an interest.
But, you know, I really didn't know
for sure.
What kind of set me on my
path was I found a school that,
a college that I had a chance
of getting into with poor grades.
And I toured it.
I remember I set up the tour
on my own because my parents hadn't
really, you know, had any experience in
how to do that.
So I remember I went ahead and
just took a bus to the train
into Boston from the suburbs where I
lived and towards Suffolk University.
And I had, there was an undergraduate
admissions counselor who took time to sit
and talk and look at your transcript
and give you some suggestions if you
wanted to apply.
And I remember he saw the graphic
arts award that I had won.
And he said, "well, you know, your
GPA isn't great.
You have some good, your testing is
okay.
But it's going to be hard with
your GPA and your class rank to
get into an English program", because I
wanted to do creative writing.
And he saw the graphic arts award
and he suggested, but we recently just
started a computer science program and we
have almost nobody applying.
And so if you apply direct to
major for computer science, your odds will
be much higher because we have almost
nobody applying for that major.
And so that's what I did.
And I got in.
And I remember I immediately persuaded the
poetry professor, Fred Marchant, who's a Boston
poet, a conscientious objector to the Vietnam
War and sort of a leader of
sort of the poetry community in New
England.
He's a really fabulous person.
I kind of begged him to get
into an upper level, 300 level poetry
workshop class that he was running.
And I was like, well, you know,
I have this computer science major thing,
but now I'm in.
I can look to making the switch
eventually.
But it turned out that I had
a knack for computer science and I
had a really good professor in my
first, in my fall, my kind of
a of a software engineering 101 or
whatever it was.
And he, Lewis Barton, he recently passed,
but he came to computer science late
in life, came back to it.
And he was just really excited to
help people who had any kind of
sort of different background, I think, be
able to make it in computer science.
And he kind of viewed himself with
that different background where where he meandered
for many years before coming back to
academia and was really looking for bright
students.
And I was lucky that I did
pretty well.
I ended up winning that, my freshman
year, their first year computer science award,
which, you know, it's a small class,
obviously, so it wasn't that big of
an accomplishment.
But for me, it was a big
accomplishment.
I didn't think that I would be
kind of exceptional at it when I
first started.
I had a really good friend who
was going to Northeastern University, Richard Buckman,
and he spent a lot of time,
evenings, just sort of passionately, you know,
showing me cool things about the C
programming language and, you know, how it
worked.
And he was, we were friends since
high school.
And him and I had a lot
of kind of in common with just
loving to learn things on our own,
not necessarily for a reason.
And he learned the C programming language
before he really had the opportunity to
program.
I think he might have taught himself
at a middle school.
And he taught himself it from the
language definition, which is called the Bacchus-Naur
form.
It's just sort of this very rigid,
you know, definition of the language without
any practical, how do you actually use
it?
But that's sort of how he approached
things.
He could learn the fundamentals and the
principles and then start pulling in examples
and being able to run.
And he sort of, that kind of
joy of doing it with him in
the evenings and this very supportive professor
during the day, you know, was a
great way to not only feel like
I was doing well academically and picking
it up, but I really ran way,
way ahead of, you know, what would
typically, where you'd end your freshman year
of college and computer science.
I ended up getting a job after
my freshman year at a startup in
Cambridge, Massachusetts programming.
And, you know, that was a pretty
quick from zero to...
Where was that?
The name of the company was Super
Wings Inc.
in Cambridge, Mass.
I think they might have been based
in Waltham or somewhere else, but they
had a satellite office.
They called it the R&D office where
myself and my good friend Rich worked
and some other people that were in
college.
And yeah, we got to do kind
of the, just that sort of the
research and development type project, sort of
new product development.
And that was really cool.
You know, there were ambitious, hard things,
but, you know, how how can you,
here's the problem, here's the opportunity.
And then we were able to actually
create at least a couple of products
during my time there.
And then the bubble burst during the
dot-com boom and then the bubble burst.
And that's where that company lost all
of its money and sort of ran
out of steam.
But you were working there during college
or still going to school?
Yes.
Yeah.
The fall of my sophomore year, I
was still attending.
I had worked, I was working at
Super Wings.
I was accepted as a special student
at MIT, which you sort of have
to do the school application for and
you get a student ID and access
to everything.
But it's a special student status.
And I took a graduate course, the
theory of computation with Michael Sipser.
I was trying to kind of beef
up my academic profile with the plan
of transferring.
And I was also taking my full
course load at Suffolk University in the
fall as well.
So it was a lot.
But you were all in.
Yeah.
I had made that transition 100% at
that point.
Yeah.
It seemed better than maybe a path
of being a poet and working in
restaurants.
And not so much that I liked
it more than I liked poetry and
literature, but it seemed like I didn't
have to give up poetry.
That I could do all of these
things that opened up a whole world
of possibilities with creativity as well.
So when was the first time that
you heard of free and open source?
It was around that time.
I think I had heard people talk
about things like Red Hat Linux and
free software.
But it wasn't until I really started
to look into it for the job
I was working at Super Wings.
We had a mix of proprietary tool
chains that we were using.
And then if I just needed some
things and not have to go through
any procurement or anything, I started discovering
that there was this was this whole
GNU system and tools available.
And I also started to encounter challenges
with proprietary software or even things that
were sort of heading towards the direction
of open source.
We did a lot of things in
Java.
And I remember having to reverse engineer
classes from the Java libraries that Sun
released.
And they hadn't yet released the source
code, but other people were working on
alternatives at the time.
And Sun was considering making theirs free
software at the time, I believe.
And so there was a lot of
intersection with it at my job.
And then when the company collapsed, that's
where I really kind of doubled down.
And I said, how much of this,
where we have costs and where we
have duplication of efforts could be reduced
if we embraced free we embraced free
software?
And then I really started reading about
the GNU project and the writings of
Richard Stallman.
of Richard Stallman.
And I wrote, when I found out
that the investors in the company, or
at least how I recall or I
recall or remember it, the investors were
sort of pulling out and that they
only had a certain amount of money
left and how it was going to
be spent.
I wrote a letter to sort of
my boss and his boss and sort
of outlining a plan that we could
keep a small office like we had,
which had low rent and everything else.
And we were making products and that
we could reduce it further if we
chose to use free software as the
basis for more of our things.
And that we could likely be able
to get even more done than what
we were getting done because we could
just build on top of these other
free software works that were out there
and available.
And one of the first pushbacks on
this idea was that in theory that
sounded good, but how can they bring
this to the investors?
My argument seems to rely so heavily
on this website and a person's writing
and it doesn't cite academic papers or
a book even.
And that didn't look well.
It didn't look good in terms of
from their perspective as being kind of
a legitimate argument.
It just felt very much like it
was my subjective opinion and then some
website online.
And it would be good to have
more.
And I don't think that was their
only gripe with it.
I'm sure there was other aspects, but
that really stood out in my mind
as one of the sort of bits
of critique or critical feedback.
And that led me to actually write
Richard Solomon an email saying, "I think
it would be great if you had
a published book so that people like
myself and these situations could cite that
book and that it could be something
that is in libraries, that is out
in the world." And for some people
who view that as being more legitimate
than something published just on the web,
that this could be very helpful.
And he liked the idea and he
said, "basically, would I be willing to
do that?
Would I be willing to lead that
project of putting together a book of
his writing and speeches?" And that if
so, he'd be able to maybe help
provide me some support and guidance from
people who have had experience publishing books
in the past.
And yeah, that's what we did.
Exactly that.
We began a project within a couple
of weeks of that email exchange.
And about a year later, or I
think less than a year later, we
published Free Software, Free Society, the Selected
Essays of Richard M.
Solomon.
And that was a great way to
get into Free Software because I sent
a lot of emails to people in
the GNU Project, fact checking or filling
in footnotes or just grappling with some
of the concepts and ideas.
And I go and I give suggested
edits and I get it all wrong
because I'm misinterpreting the writing.
And it was a pretty daunting task.
Richard Solomon himself, while being a famous
hacker and sort of the person who
helped create the Free Software Movement in
the GNU Project, is also famous for
his rigidity of language and exactness of
wording and definitions.
And he's very good at that.
And he's a very clear writer.
So editing a person who has very
strong opinions about how you say things
and how you write them and the
words you use was itself a very
daunting task because quite often I would
put forth my suggestions or rewording and
I would get very strong rejections, not
necessarily the best bedside manners from him.
He wasn't always very polite about it.
Or he would get very frustrated that
I was not understanding something.
But that's okay.
For me, I leaned on having a
background in having been a waiter and
a bartender and sort of customer service
and how to deal with unruly clients.
I just sort of leaned into that
a bit more.
I just put out a a particular
way in which I would start doing
exchanges.
That worked out quite well.
I learned a lot about engaging with
strong personalities of the Free Software community
within my first year of getting involved
into Free Software.
When did you learn about the topic
and about the philosophy?
Yeah, that was at that job that
I was working, the startup.
I just started reading about it from
the GNU.org website and also seeing it
in practice of being able to run
software where I could get the source
code and I could look at it.
It being a time where I was
learning, everything was new, that was super
exciting.
I got to see how other people
wrote code.
I didn't get to see that very
often.
I had textbook examples and things like
that, but not good full large application
development or system software development.
That was really incredible being able to
do that.
And it wasn't just the GNU project
things.
I remember one of the first bits
of source code I also had read
early on was, I think it was
the source code to LiveJournal, a website
that used to exist for people to
blog in journal.
And And one of the novel things
that it had was infinitely nested comments.
I think it was pretty early on
that I maybe it was pretty early
on that I maybe read the code
for how that worked and things like
that.
And it was cool to just see
code, like look at code that was
doing something new that I appreciated on
the internet.
That really got me excited.
I think that I was young and
idealistic and I wasn't necessarily concerned with
the practicalities of how businesses work or
making a living.
It was all just feeling like this
is amazing, this is how it should
be.
That really helped being in that mindset
and being in that learning and absorbent
mindset.
And I was hooked pretty quickly that
this seemed like a really good thing.
And what did the book do for
you?
Did that lead anywhere for you?
It definitely made me start to think
about how else it could apply.
So one thing that we did with
the book is we decided that we
should go get somebody to do an
introduction that maybe wasn't squarely related to
the GNU Project or open source.
I emailed, cold emailed Lawrence Lessig.
At the time he was a professor
at Stanford, I believe.
He was just starting Creative Commons.
I believe his book, Code, may have
been released the year before.
He had just done a major case
that went before the Supreme Court that
related to the Copyright Extension Act, Congress
extending the length of copyright retroactively.
Maybe it was Eldred versus Ashcroft, if
I recall, was the case.
Eldred was his client and he went
to the Supreme Court and argued before
it and unfortunately lost.
But he's this really charismatic, impassioned professor
saying, "let's take these principles of free
software and apply them to the creative
world and other works of creative expression
and creating the Creative Commons and licensing
suite." That idea that a person that's
doing that should be the introduction to
Richard Solomon's work philosophically really helped me
understand that free software is a concept
you can apply or open source as
people know it.
That's exactly what we've seen.
We've seen now people say open source
and then they'll say open hardware, open
science, open data, open education and all
of these other things.
But at the time open source itself,
the term was 18 months old and
free software had been the word.
But there wasn't a lot of people
saying, let's apply what they're doing in
the free and open source software world
to these other things.
There were.
I wasn't at all unique.
Wikipedia and other things were getting off
the ground at that time.
But even those, the world was very
small.
When Wikipedia started, the way that the
GNU project tried to influence them was
by competing and launching a GNUpedia project
which licensed things under a free documentation
license.
When Wikipedia made some evolutionary changes, it
decided to adopt that GNUpedia approach and
take those licensed work and then GNUpedia
said, well, I'm done.
That was all we wanted to accomplish.
They finished their work because Wikipedia decided
to adopt this free documentation license.
As those things were happening and I
was getting really excited about looking at
things like textbooks and free educational works,
what could we do there?
They're functional in nature.
Collaboration would greatly benefit them.
Licensing, you can almost think of them
as modular like software is and you
can piece them together.
I really started to put a lot
of energy into that area of work
really early on and always looking for
what are other people doing?
Are they doing the same thing in
open science and open data and things
like that?
And how is this philosophy being applied?
That mindset from day one and not
necessarily just the let's build the operating
system or I'm going to make a
career continuing to do software development.
I almost abandoned that at that point.
I still had a desire to learn
more in kind of a research academic
setting.
I continued on with my school career,
but at the same time, I put
in just as much time into these
other passions as I was finishing my
college degree.
When you graduated, was that where you
got into the open education piece?
Where did you go from?
When I was at UMass Amherst, which
is where I transferred after Suffolk University,
I guess that would be the fall
of 2001.
That's when I think the book Free
Software, Free Society came out and I
was working in the hand-eye limb lab
at the robotics lab at the University
of Massachusetts Amherst.
I think having something so physical and
real made me think, how do I
build on this?
Even if I wasn't immersed with people
that were also doing that, it got
me excited that I could finish something
substantial with people in a year.
So I started looking for other kinds
of projects.
I started a concept project that year
called the Free Textbook Project.
It had a vision statement, a goal,
trying to drum up support, get people
to buy into the idea, see if
people might be interested in making it
happen.
What exactly was it?
Can you give a long line description?
Yeah, absolutely.
Basically, the vision was to create an
initiative to create the tools and the
content for people to be able to
put out free and open source licensed
textbooks, K-12 and college, with the idea
that especially for STEM type topics, let's
also build a library of example problem
sets and concepts and make it easier
at a very modular level to be
able to form units and to craft
text and use as other teaching materials.
If you want to produce your lectures,
if you want to actually have full
books, all being from the same base
that we collaborate on and structured in
that way, where you have this base
level almost operating system that you then
have initiatives on top of.
Let's have the specific biology book.
Yes, we might have to focus on
that, but we feed down into that
base level source material.
That was the pitch, the concept of
it.
It led to, in pitching and talking
about it, it led to other opportunities
that were in the neighborhood, projects that
had already gotten off the ground.
Did this one get off the ground?
This one didn't get very far.
I felt like I would need a
substantial number of people who had experience
doing this work and creating it.
I just didn't feel like it was
something that I had the competency to
just start doing and making.
It was more a startup-type approach with
a pitch and trying to get some
seed funding around the idea and a
small website that did exist for quite
a long time.
It didn't really make it past that,
but in going out there and pitching
the idea, I was able to find
other people doing similar projects or similar
in kind, or that might be considered
a piece of this broader vision that
I had.
There was a website, a blog that
Jason Turgeon created called Textbook Revolution.
It was just published a bunch of
listings and reviews of various...
If you're a teacher and you're making
your book freely available online, here's a
quick little library-type entry and a link
to it.
If need be, we would store the
file if it was above board.
I took over that project and ran
it for a number of years.
For a long time, it was the
largest and biggest resource for freely available
or educational, K-12, mostly college, but some
K-12 textbooks and course readers and things
like that.
What was it called?
Textbook Revolution.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Why don't we stop here and take
a little break and then we'll come
back.
Awesome.
Thanks.
We're back on.
When we left off, what did you
do after you graduated?
All these things you've done before that,
we're still also in school.
Yeah.
I met my now-wife while I was
in college and she...
Meredith.
Meredith Beaton.
Meredith was at Wellesley College in Wellesley,
Massachusetts.
It's an all-women's college.
She got a degree in computer science
and a minor in math.
I got a degree in math and
a minor in computer science.
We both have this passion, but coming
at it from different angles around education.
The Free Textbook Project to me was
really a way to empower learners and
especially, I think I probably projected a
lot of myself onto other learners, people
who love to be able to go
out there and learn on their own
or at their own pace or to
make it easy to adapt curriculum to
learners like myself.
I'm pretty sure I probably, at that
time, it wasn't much more sophisticated than
that.
That was informing the design of it.
Meredith also had a passion for education.
She applied for graduate school at Columbia
University and got accepted to the Teachers
College at Columbia.
After we graduated, we moved to New
York, a little apartment on the Upper
West Side.
I didn't have a job.
I started the applying for two kinds
of jobs.
One was leaning on my background in
editing.
After I published Free Software, Free Society
and I got a lot of experience
in publishing, one of the gigs I
had in addition to some other jobs
in college was being a copy editor.
I was able to put out, copy
edit four or five large volumes of
work for them.
Nothing too exciting, but I got trained
by Ann Costante, who in the math
publishing world was somewhat famous and really
amazing.
It was a really great thing.
I learned so much and gained so
many skills that it seemed silly to
not apply those after college.
I applied to small publishing houses.
I really did want to learn how
could I do this free textbook project
by myself if I can't get funding
and hire people to do it.
I also applied for software development jobs.
The first one I got was at
at a small publisher that focused on
writing texts and supplementary works to textbooks
and some textbooks, but that was a
hard thing to gain entrance into.
It was run by an owner, an
operator, wear every hat and hire contractors
and others as he can.
One of the things that really made
me want to work for him is
I pitched for him the idea behind
the free textbook project in in my
interview.
He said, "I'm looking to get out
of this.
If this works out, maybe you could
take over this company and you could
convert it." Although the odds of that
happening were very low, it was enough
to get me to accept the job
offer for not much pay on the
spot.
That's what I started out doing.
That didn't last but a few months.
Pay was challenging.
The work was really demanding, really fast-paced.
I tried to turn over tests and
other things that basically textbook companies needed
done on short order.
They would go to him and he
would go to me and say, a
hundred problems or something.
I couldn't keep up that kind of
pace and it didn't work out, but
I learned a ton in that short
period of time.
Then I went on and I got
a programming job for Harris Corporations briefly.
I tried to convert them to Freed
Open Source Software while I was there
in my brief time for a few
months.
And then my wife...
Any ill-luck?
No, No, not really.
I persuaded one director in the company.
They had an old system.
It was a trading system for people
buying airtime for commercials, national and local
TV commercials.
You have this whole real-time bidding of
the agents who are buying commercial slots
or trying to for their clients and
whoever has a commercial to sell and
the network televisions.
It was a pretty cool system because
in New York, where all of those
people were, they had had this system
running continuously since the 80s with almost
no downtime because basically buying slots for
commercials is something that happens 24 hours
a day.
There's always adjustments on prices and things
like that.
I learned a ton, but because it
was such an old system and just
mainframe style approach, they had a very
slow and rigorous process for updating it
with new records and things.
I wrote a system where you could
fill in templates with the record information
you wanted.
Then a Python script that would spit
out all the C code that was
meticulous that used a lot of old
data structures and things like that that
weren't really used anymore.
It was carefully putting all the information
into as little memory as possible because
back in the 80s, that was really
important.
At that point in 2003 or whatever
it was, it wasn't nearly as important.
It was a lot of work to
keep the system going.
Some people were really excited by taking
these tools and I wanted to release
it as a general templating engine in
Python that could be used for this
system.
I got it working, but I didn't
stick around long enough to actually give
it to the company to release it
as an open source project.
Then my wife managed to compress her
two-year program into a year and decided
she wanted to go back to computer
science.
I was excited to go back to
computer science.
I missed working in a lab, which
I was fortunate enough to do for
three years at UMass Amherst.
We both applied to the University of
Oklahoma.
I applied there because my advisor from
UMass had just gotten a professorship there.
She was motivated to apply there because
she's from Oklahoma.
She wanted to be able to spend
a little be able to spend a
little bit more time with family.
It's a program that we could potentially
both get into.
We did.
I got in provisionally if I could
pass some courses.
She got in directly into the PhD
program in computer science there.
That's where we went next.
It was there where I really started
to get back to doing more with
free and open source software in general.
I started you know in addition to
working in this wonderful symbiotic machine learning
lab doing computational neuroscience work, I was
sort of moonlighting starting a Oklahoma non-profit
called the Commons Development Foundation.
And there I was exploring this idea
of how do we take these ideas
of free software and apply them either
to new areas in a sense or
even how do we take some of
the best ideas of what was emerging
at the time as sort of community,
what some might describe as sort of
the open source philosophy, the development of
it, this collaborative collective action type work.
How do we apply that back to
sort of the older free software movement
which didn't always necessarily which didn't always
necessarily apply that.
It had moral principles and ethics but
the collaborative aspect of the distributed collaborative
aspect of things like Wikipedia and whatnot
weren't necessarily evenly you you know catching
up.
It's sort of this race of some
doing it really well in some areas
and lagging behind at others at that
time.
And so I began working with Solona
Bohnwald who's a she previously had been
doing some work with EFF and ACLU
down in Austin, Texas and she was
really excited to start doing a government
transparency project and built on free software
and she formed this thing called the
League of Technical Voters which was to
sort of launch these initiatives and I
was exploring similar things.
I decided to create something called MagnaWiki,
a way to do annotations and revisioning
of legislative texts so drafts of bills
and things like that and so I
was regularly calling legislative aides and things
and getting their input and they were
excited they were saying yes you want
to make tools non-profit to make our
job easier to comment to compare and
things like that.
They were surprisingly very receptive and willing
to give their time and so I
was able to find some other like-minded
people like Solona down in Texas and
then similarly the Sunlight Foundation had just
started led by Ellen Miller and funded
by and led by Michael Klein and
so you know I was also reaching
out to them finding opportunities for you
know potentially getting funding from them.
They had me submit a full kind
of grant proposal through the Commons Development
Foundation on MagnaWiki and made it through
a few rounds which was pretty exciting
and at the same time locally in
Norman, Oklahoma I worked with the Triangle
Fraternity, an engineering fraternity, not Delta, Triangle
and maybe the only frat I probably
would ever consider joining.
It's really wonderful frat of of engineers
with really great attitudes and I work
with them on doing a sort of
a 24-hour hackathon event and it had
a mix of things including writing code
but also making musical instruments so it
had this sort of Maker Faire type
aspect and a number of other activities
and we invited people just from the
community as well to come and join
and partake in addition to the student
population.
I started to reach out to, I
started to put together proposals for the
free textbook initiative, that free textbook project
that I was still pursuing and also
I put together a proposal to the
Free Software Foundation to launch something called
Libre Planet where I suggested we kind
of take this idea of using wikis
and other tools as a way to
do distributed organizing around sort of issue
campaigns that mattered to the free and
open source software world as well as
to organize both local events and sort
of a larger conference and this was
all great.
It was a lot to be doing
on top of making next to nothing
as a research assistant in the lab
and by the end of the year
I decided that I probably shouldn't stay
enrolled and pursue a degree and my
wife decided that going the full PhD
route was not what she wanted.
She really wanted to go and use
that education degree so she started applying
for teaching positions.
At the same time I started to
look for either keeping the Commons Development
Foundation running or taking on a role
elsewhere.
I ended up meeting with the Sunlight
Foundation, the One Laptop per Child project
which was just getting off the ground
and meeting with the Free Software Foundation
and I settled on the Free Software
Foundation as a full-time job as one
of their first of two campaigns managers
to run issue-based campaigning.
They really was sort of building on
this contract that I had started with
them to do Libre Planet which that
work had already begun and was underway
and did lead to exactly that a
wiki that had some distributed collaboration and
conference and the annual conference happens every
year in March now going on since
I don't know know 2005-2006.
I can't remember when they did their
first one.
So we moved back to Boston.
My wife helped build the middle school
program at Cambridge Montessori School and became
a Montessori certified teacher.
She taught all the subjects except for
art and wrote the curriculum and most
of the source material, a lot of
it from primary sources.
So I just say that because that's
a lot of work and so I
spent many a weekend in her classroom
for three years straight and during the
weekday I would work at the Free
Software Foundation and in the evenings I
would spend a lot of my evenings
at the One Laptop per Child project
over in Kendall Square in Cambridge, Massachusetts,
sort of volunteering for them.
Talk a little bit about the Free
Software Foundation and what it was like
to work there.
Were you reunited with the Richard Stallman
as well?
So yeah Richard, when I was working
on the book one summer I did
a two-month internship at the Free Software
Foundation.
Bradley Kuhn was the executive director at
the time.
He eventually went on to work with
the Software Freedom Law Center when it
first started and then launched the Software
Freedom Conservancy, an organization he helped to
found and is now led by Karen
Sandler.
So my first sort of time in
the office was when Bradley was in
charge and they were just, you know,
at that time I don't think I
saw Richard Stallman except maybe once or
twice.
It really was just operating, you know,
executive director and below and didn't really
have much engagement with Richard or the
rest of the board.
And then when I came back as
an employee, as a campaigns manager, it
was similar.
So Peter Brown became the executive director
at that time.
John Sullivan was the other campaigns manager.
He went on to become eventually the
executive director the executive director for many
years, shortly thereafter, maybe a few years
after I started there.
And they had unionized, so they were
a local under the United Auto Workers.
And in part, you know, that union
and that bargaining and that contract helped
set kind of some firm boundaries, I
think, in part between Richard and the
board.
Richard, as a founder of a small,
passionate organization for many years that, you
know, was sort of having to keep
it going himself largely, I think anybody
in that situation sometimes have a hard
time stepping back and not just injecting
themselves, right?
And him, maybe more so than others,
was at times injecting himself and coming
down and sort of, you know, directing
the staff or, you know, influencing changes.
And so they put in place that
union, which really helped protect the roles
and the reporting and everything.
And so when I had arrived, that
was already established.
And I would say, you know, the
interactions with Richard were more structured in
general.
And, you know, there would be collaborations
on things, maybe send text for feedback
to Richard, or maybe there would be
specific be specific things that he would
be giving his direct input on or
would need to be the final say
on.
But it didn't feel like I worked
for him ever.
Peter Brown and then later John Sullivan
did a really good job of sort
of establishing that and enforcing that separation
between, you know, management and everybody below
that was in the union.
And that really helped.
It made it a healthier environment, I
think, than it might have otherwise been.
Because Richard did travel immensely at times,
you know, giving well over 100 talks
a year around the world, which means,
you know, he would just sort of
swoop in and, you know, try to
get a whole bunch of things done
at once.
And if you're a person trying to,
you know, just have a job and
get your things done, that can be
very disruptive and very difficult.
And, you know, they did a really
nice job of helping to balance, you
know, that and preventing those disruptions by
the time I had arrived.
I know that the people I worked
with previously had gone through a lot
of that and it was very challenging.
But it was a good time.
You know, they were really transitioning from
kind of selling the GNU project code
on CDs as a primary means of
income to creating a membership based organization
where, you know, they're kind of surviving
on an associate membership that gives, you
know, between $100 and $200 a year,
small gifts.
And for me, I really was excited
by that because my goal was to
try to create a distributed kind of
collaborative approach to supporting free software, supporting
end user rights and things, as well
as bringing support to free software communities
and developers.
And so it was a really good
time to join that organization.
I felt like I was able to
do just that.
I was privileged to be able to
every day interact with, you know, people
all over the world that wanted help
with one thing or another or making
people aware of things that at the
time seemed kind of very fringe topics,
you know.
You know, why are you protesting Microsoft
or these other things?
And nowadays, if I talk about the
same things that we were protesting, the
specific issues, it's so clear to people.
They're like, oh, that's terrible.
Of course, nobody would accept that today.
And, you know, so it was very
rewarding because there weren't a lot of
other people in the space doing that.
Now there is.
Now there's a lot more people who
are out there and digital rights are
just just part of, I think, all
other things, all other consumer rights.
They're not as separate.
It's not like there's just Microsoft and
Apple and that's it.
Now it's, you know, people are very
aware of there being a lot of
choice and that, you know, terms and
conditions and how, you know, how you
treat your users and your customers as
being your community, right?
That has all shifted as an attitude
in business.
And it was fun being a part
of that at the Free Software Foundation,
really, really sort of feeling that shift
happening and, you know, getting out there
and doing work and supporting free software
communities.
But what do you think your biggest
contribution there was during your time there?
I would say helping to, I would
say the thing that I have seen
the biggest impact on wasn't necessarily just
creating the work, like helping to do
the work of the Free Software Foundation
and their campaigns.
I mean, that was an important contribution
to help create their campaigns team and
their methodologies and shift the business, in
a sense, to being more of a
consumer awareness, consumer activist org.
I think it was more helping the
individual developers and others who were trying
to do something and being able to
support them.
So one of the initiatives I was
able to help get going was the
Respect Your Freedom Certification Program, where sellers
of devices, hardware could submit to the
Respect Your Freedom Certification Program, their device,
and we would have a bunch of
criteria, you know, does it let you
install free software?
Does it have, does it not?
You know, how does it respect these
different sort of freedoms that relate to
free and open source software?
And what was exciting is that, you
know, sometimes I would be in conversation
with somebody who wanted a device to
exist, right?
And in one case, somebody wanted this
whole secondary market of think pads and
things to run free software and to
be certified and to be able to
be resold.
So I was able to just sort
of support ideas of, well, this is
what that would look like.
You would need to sell devices.
You should probably also consider making a
project about doing this work in and
of itself that can be promoted, right?
So that you can, as a company,
actually have other people participating in the
thing that you don't have to do
it all yourself.
And seeing things like that actually get
off the ground and then form a
company, then form a project.
And that happened a number of times
in different spaces with routers and laptops.
Just sort of feeling as though, even
though, you know, our certification doesn't reach
some wide audience, it's not even, you
know, a true certification mark or anything
that we created.
Like you would have, say, Certified Organic
where you have you have an independent
testing lab and things.
It was the same company issuing the
certification was running the testing.
It allowed for this other way of
supporting free software communities of saying, look,
this does matter.
You know, you having sustainable businesses that
have these values and getting those off
the ground and projects that could be
sustained, that can have funding.
That was really meaningful and valuable work.
And I felt like it not only
helped those individual communities, but when sharing
and meeting with other community managers and
other people doing this kind of work,
it allowed me to help contribute to
that bigger picture.
How else are you doing this?
How are you doing it in these
other contexts?
And I would say that's really where
the work I did there was amplified
across multiple different sort of communities, both
within the free software world through them
and that engaging other communities outside of
the FSF.
Oh, that's really cool.
That's really cool.
And why don't we stop here for
a couple minutes and I'm just going
to put the right thing there.
Okay, we're back on.
And you had been at the Free
Software Foundation.
What was your next move after that?
So because I was still kind of
moonlighting with these other projects and still
going out there pitching this free textbook
project, which just had so many pieces
to try to get off the ground
was really hard.
I ended up getting connected with Neeru
Khosla.
She had just started a project called
the CK12 Foundation, a new company organization.
And her and her husband had been
in Silicon Valley for quite a while
then.
She had a master's in I think
molecular biology.
He founded Sun Microsystems and went on
to be a successful and is a
successful venture capitalist with Kleiner Perkins Coalfield
Buyers and now the Khosla Ventures.
So they were doing quite well when
they started the CK12 Foundation.
Her kids had sort of gotten, she
has four children and they had grown
up and she was ready to be
able to put more focus into sort
of a next endeavor in life.
And her and Merg and Pal founded
the CK12 Foundation to create sort of
these flex books, free and open textbook
system where educators could go and just
download freely licensed K through 12 textbooks
that were of good quality and sort
of standards aligned and things like that.
So right up there in here, that's
exactly.
Also this idea of modularity and remixing
of them and being able to break
it down all the way down to
building, you know, their vision was very
similar in terms of at the end
of the day, ultimately having kind of
very modular things and being able to
make it easy for learners to customize
to that individual learner as well as
to support the educator who wants to
create their own custom curriculum or add
to it.
So yeah, I flew out to Palo
Alto and met with them.
And even though things were going great
at the Free Software Foundation, the opportunity
seemed, you know, it was too perfectly
aligned with another passion of mine that
I had been trying to get off
the ground and felt like the way
to actually do it would require a
lot of resources.
And well, the COSAs had the resources
and the passion and a shared vision.
And they poured it in to paying
not just writers and editors and software
developers, but also hiring, you know, people
to align the content to state standards,
putting in the work of getting Governor
Schwarzenegger to pass a governor's, you know,
I forget what it was called, but
it was a declaration to support free
and open textbooks in the state of
California for standards alignment to pilot it.
And they were able to sort of
be able to work at it at
all these levels and have the resources
to marshal that.
And they hired me for this multi
kind of this role that sat between
the software engineers who are creating the
platform and the tooling and editors and
the content producers.
And to be able to be the
sort of the technical content editor that
sits between them to help inform the
design of the system, be able to
communicate and effectively translate between the two
and to create and host an intermediary
solution for them.
So I set up the same software
that Wikipedia uses, MediaWiki instance that allowed
for things to be input kind of
somewhat easily converting from Word documents and
other things that the writers were using
into a more, you know, text based
structured thing that could then be kind
of ready to feed into this online
tool and system and archive.
And so that was just an amazing
opportunity.
And it was a great, you know,
almost two years of my life where
I would go out there often two
or three weeks at a time and
then come back and work remotely.
But it became, you know, most of
my focus where I had a lot
of side projects going on over that
two year period but before then, most
of those went away because this was
just something to get off the ground
and build momentum behind.
And I think I maybe burnt out
a bit after two years.
It became a bit much, but it's
gone on to be a very successful
project, getting them sort of through their
pilot program and getting books into school
systems at the state level in multiple
states felt like I was a part
of something really big and a really
hard problem at the time that helped
kind of, you know, break through a
barrier that now many are able to
more easily get through.
You can get sort of these other
learning platforms accepted into schools of these
different ways more easily.
And I think CK12 Foundation and the
Coastals really helped do that.
Mergen Pal had a background in doing
open source.
He had a company previously that was
focused on providing open source consultancy and
services to other tech tech companies in
Silicon Valley.
So we really hit it off.
He's a brilliant architect in terms of
how to go about building an information
system that could achieve these sort of
lofty goals.
And it was a really special time
in my life to have been a
part of that.
And after I finished that work, I
didn't go straight back to the Free
Software Foundation, but I was fortunate enough
to get some contracting work.
I worked with Mozilla and Peer2Peer U.
I was able to help them launch
their first open badges system, which really
built on a lot of that kind
of visionary education work.
What does it look like to put
work out into the world, right?
To basically, here's how you can put
a badge pathway out into the world
of curriculum that can be followed and
recognized that isn't part of the formal
education system per se, but could be.
And to find some subtle, important choices
about what this would look like.
Embedding metadata in the image itself was,
you know, here's the image of a
badge recognition.
It carries with it this metadata about
who awarded it to you, what it
means, some sort of fundamental decisions early
on I got to be a part
of.
And I got to be a part
of a process of facilitating many different
kinds of stakeholders and potentially interested parties
and hosting events where we were able
to fly them in and get together
in a room and brainstorm.
And then have a week-long sprint of
doing this work with collaborators in Barcelona,
Spain, where we ran the badge lab
and badge workshops at the first Mozilla
Festival, which I believe it's called the
Mozilla Festival now.
Back then, they had branded it their
drumbeat festival.
And that was really wonderful with Peer
to Peer U, an initiative of sort
of peer to peer educating on a
platform.
I got to work on a number
of similar kind of education initiatives that
melded it well into the badging ecosystem.
That was a really great interlude between
CK12 and going back to the Free
Software Foundation, where I came back briefly
as the campaigns manager again and sort
of imposing digital restrictions management and promoting
open formats and raising awareness about how
patents and the threat of patents that
gets freed up with our software really
create this huge threat and burden to
transitioning from all of that work to
being the licensing and compliance manager for
the Free Software Foundation, which led to
sort of in in my mind, a
lot of similar type of work of
getting to engage the community, not necessarily
needing to try to do this is
so urgent type campaigning, where every issue
is, you know, a giant urgent threat
that you need to take action now
on.
It was, you know, a slightly slower
pace, but equally rewarding.
Basically, they have an email address, licensing
at fsf.org, and whether you're a lawyer
or a developer or whomever, and you
have questions about freedom of software licensing,
you just email them and then they'll
answer you.
And it turns out that the new
general public license and the suite of
licenses being the most adopted and used
freedom of software license in the world
at the time, led to a very
large volume of people asking for help
and support and often in very, you
know, important situations of their company or
whatever it may be, their project.
And so that was a very rewarding
thing to be a part of.
I got even, whereas I felt the
campaigns management work definitely allowed me to
connect to so many people in the
public.
I think that the licensing and compliance
lab work was tenfold, in a sense.
There was just so many more people
that I was directly helping day to
day.
And at the same time, also being
able to sort of do work at
another level.
So I was able to write, you
know, requests for comments from the government
when new things are happening and they're
printed in the federal register, you know,
you can go ahead and submit comments.
So I was able to do that
and, you know, set up meeting with
the FCC at one time.
And, you know, even though it was,
you know, for that work, it was
one and a half employees with occasional
input from others.
It felt like we were able to
have this huge impact on being able
to have this grounding in a very
fundamentally important part of this, of digital
infrastructure, the licensing.
It created this sort of inroad to
let's make sure that the policies or
the laws and other things are sort
of all fitting well together, right?
You know, if this policy requires certain
conditions, it means that these licenses could
not be used and be legal in
certain cases, right?
And so that is a very real
thing.
It's not theoretic.
Here's all the software under these licenses
and here's why they can't run on
these devices if you have these laws.
And it's very concrete and not philosophical.
I mean, maybe you can frame it
as being grounded in ethics or you
can just be practical and say, a
bunch of freely available software can't run
on these legally and be in compliance.
So that was a really powerful sort
of work I got to be a
part of that could, you know, go
out there and sort of advocate for
the free and open source software world.
Able to work with the Creative Commons
when they did their, I believe, the
4.0 suite of licenses.
I was able to work closely with
their lawyers on compatibility of CC BISA
4.0 and the GNU GPL.
So you're able to get into what
got published.
It is compatible.
You can take a CC BISA 4.0
work and you can relicense it as
a GNU GPL version 3.0 license work.
And, you know, for some people that
wasn't usually important, but where it matters
has been very important.
It allows for people to go from
that sort of creative level of work
to be able to move it into
sort of the free and open source
software licensing world from a Creative Commons
licensing world and bridging that gap and
making sure that the licenses are sort
of, you know, in everybody's view, comparable
enough, right?
And getting that buy-in and acceptance from
communities that these are solving similar problems
and that they're considered compatible.
You can't go the other direction because
of the terms of the GNU General
Public License.
It doesn't allow you to relicense in
other terms that are not the GNU
General Public License.
But getting that one-way compatibility was hard
enough.
And that was a really great thing
to be a part of.
We were able to make some, interact
with the W3C standards on the web
to have license tags in HTML be
accepted when deciding if a website is
fully in compliance with the W3C standards.
Here are some custom tags.
We were able to work with a
community called the Microformats community as an
intermediary to create, to make those tags
considered, accepted as part of HTML5.
You know, and these are just things
that are, they're not necessarily a big
deal for the Free Software Foundation.
But the idea that we're working across
so many different types of communities where
free and open source software matters and
these licensing issues or these technical issues
are run into a problem.
Having that compatibility means that a person
who has a policy in their job
or in their government, that it has
to pass all the tests in order
for them to use that.
If it doesn't pass the tests, they
don't get to use it.
If it does, they do.
It's as simple as that.
But understanding that there are these sort
of keystones to sort of the global
digital infrastructure and the policies of the
laws was really, you know, it was
a privilege to be able to be
able to sort of sit in between
communities of people, their problems, suggestions on
where that problem is.
That'd be able to go advocate and
make changes on their behalf.
It It was really just a privilege.
It was really great work and I'm
proud of what we were able to
accomplish in those few years that I
worked with them.
When did you leave?
In 2017, I guess it would be.
I think that's right.
Is that right?
Yeah.
I guess it'll be my sixth year
at the IEEE where I work now,
the IEEE Standard Association.
What led me here, really, that work
started when I was with the Free
Software Foundation.
I was invited to be a member
of an associate of the Berkman Center,
which is now the Berkman Clyde Center
at Harvard Law School.
They run a cyber law clinic and
they sort of this melting pot of
think tank type group at the intersection
of policy and law and technology.
I was invited to come and be
an associate.
They have fellows and associates there.
During my time there, one of the
things I did was try to reflect
on this idea of there being this
kind of global digital infrastructure.
There's this feeling of free software.
It opens our software.
It's starting to be accepted by business,
by consumers, things like Android and other
platforms really that were open source at
the time, really just sort of shifting
the marketplace.
All of a sudden, put the importance
on looking at global institutions, it just
made it more important.
How do we go from where we
are now, kind of as this grassroots,
to bringing the same ethos of the
grassroots into the institution so it's into
the institution so it's not just captured
by just the corporate address who's accepting
it now?
The one blog post I wrote while
I was there, and it's still up,
I guess I wrote two.
One was on health and fitness, health
and fitness, health and fitness, health and
fitness, an area I was exploring.
Maybe this is a way that I
could touch more lives and can matter,
but that felt like a dead end
and not quite big enough.
So what I started to focus on
was standards and standardization and starting really
kind of how do we go the
other direction, not how do we get
standards development orgs and those who value
standardization, but how do we help influence
the free software projects and open source
software projects to start to think about
standards?
And so the focus was on how
to prepare for standardization at the start
of your project, how to approach your
open source project as maybe later on
in its life becoming the start or
the basis for a technology, an industry
standard, a global standard.
And this really led down sort of
eventually when I left the FSF and
started to look for my next major
sort of thing that I wanted to
be a part of, eventually ended up
with the IEEE standards association where we're
kind of coming at it from both
directions.
We're a a unified platform and support
for general free and open source software
projects, which is great, but also we've
updated our policies and procedures to allow
our standards working groups to incorporate open
source at any number of ways in
there into their standards.
And so sort of coming at it
from both ends has been really great.
It's been able to do exactly sort
of this idea, this direction that I
hoped we could go, I could bring
my career.
And I was just lucky enough that
the one major international standards org needed
a full-time remote open source specialist that
had a background in licensing and software
development and community management and all the
different hats I've ever worn was more
or less what was the list of
this would be nice to have in
this job.
It felt written for me.
And it's hard to imagine actually at
this point in my life ever leaving
the IEEE.
It really is an institution that is
a global member-driven, member-run 501c3 nonprofit doing
work that matters at an institutional level.
And, you know, I should disclaim on
this talk that all of my opinions
are my own and not of my
employer right now.
What does IEEE stand for?
You should probably clarify that.
Yeah, so the Institute of Electrical and
Electronics Engineers.
This is its second name.
It was the American Institute of Electrical
Engineers in the 1880s or 1890s when
it incorporated.
And then when they merged with the
Radio Institute of America, I can't remember
the name of the other technical society
they merged with in the 60s.
They did a name revision and a
merger at the same time.
So the AIEE became the IEEE.
The name doesn't necessarily match up with
what they do, per se.
They cover sort of a very wide
range of technical endeavors, all engineering still,
very technical, with a focus on local
work, promoting scholarly publications, innovation, and standardization,
but with a mission for promoting technology
for the benefit of humanity, which is
sort of, as an employee there, as
part of that community, that mission feels
very much present in everything.
You really feel like you are creating
technology that's for the benefit of humanity,
which is exciting.
And it's the most passionate group of
volunteers I've ever worked with, who put
in more time and energy than I
thought was possible.
And I'm a person who has just
spent 20 years of my career feeling
like I put in so much extra
time into all of these volunteer things.
And I feel blown out of the
water with many of the volunteers I
work with.
They'll put in, I'll meet with them
sometimes two or three times a week,
now over a period of years where
they'll be going off and flying around
the world, giving talks of things often
on their own dime or on their
employer's dime, just really creating things.
And it's exciting because here's this old
institution.
It has plenty of its flaws and
other things, but it's exciting because I'm
learning so much from them and being
able to bring in and share so
much from the free and open source
software world and this melding is happening.
And I feel like already we're starting
to see the benefits of that, of
bringing together these different types of communities
that have their own contemporary histories and
approaches to doing global global collaboration and
technology development.
That's fantastic.
It sounds like everything just really came
together.
Yeah, and I feel really lucky.
And I should say when that job
came up, it ended up, it came
to me, but three people had recommended
to the hiring manager, me, and they
had sent, other people had sent me
the job description.
It was that community that I've been
pouring myself into, whether it was part
of my day job or just part
of one of my many different volunteer
jobs, they were there for me.
And that felt really great because I'm
usually just a person who's saying, how
can I help?
And then when I needed help and
then something like this, to know that
people thought of me and that I
was a part of that and that
I was a good fit for this
kind of, potentially a good fit for
this kind of work, that's really meaningful.
It really carries me day to day,
knowing that even if we're not always
communicating or staying in touch, that there's
enough people out there that view the
importance of this network of being there
for each other, thinking of each other,
making sure that we aren't just necessarily
getting a job, but we're able to
try to have the impact in the
ways we want to be able to
hear the things that I'm maybe pretty
good at or that I have experience
doing.
How could these be useful?
And that there's a lot of people
out there in the free and open
source software world that really get that.
And they're like, "oh yeah, I get
it.
You've done these things." "That'd be great.
You could help do these other things
really well." "That would be so awesome."
And those kinds of helping us, whether
it's on our careers or to get
projects off the ground or to go
and spend time even volunteering or supporting
one way or another each other's work,
really feels, it's just indescribable community, the
free and open source software.
Yeah, the community aspect just is huge.
That's so much a part of it.
I want to ask you, how do
you think the community has changed since
you first got into it?
Yeah, so I would say maybe the
biggest change is in the first 10,
maybe almost 15 years that I was
a part of it, I couldn't really
go more than a week or two
without having a conversation about questioning the
legitimacy of it at a very fundamental
level.
But asking, well, how do you pay
for it?
Or how can a business do that?
Or why should they give this all
away?
Or just very fundamental questions were constantly
being asked by anybody I was interacting
with, even people that were a part
of it.
And just feeling maybe not confident about
it.
They might be doing it, but it
could feel so tenuous that like, could
this just go on?
Is this ever going to be like,
how do we actually keep doing this?
To now, where I don't necessarily think
people are on the whole more informed
of what free and open source software
is.
But the legitimacy of it, that it's
here, that it's established, is so strong
that when you start talking about it,
they don't immediately go to questioning those
fundamentals nearly as often.
Now I have gone maybe two years
almost, I would say, at this point.
I can't recall a single question along
the lines which I used to get,
which would surprise me if I could
go more than two weeks without having
that kind of conversation about how you
pay for it.
And we used to have to frame
it that way, right?
So we'd have to explain to people,
we'd have little catchphrases and Free Software
would say, no, no, it's free as
in freedom, not as in beer.
Now we don't have to explain what
free and open source software is relative
to other goods or that it's a
matter of principle or other things.
We can just talk about it and
the fact that we're not, it's not
constantly trying to commoditize it or profit
off of it or control it.
It's just sort of understood that it
works in the same realm as Wikipedia
and other things that people value and
appreciate.
To me, that's the biggest difference.
And that's where I think us seeing
the next phase of what does this
mean now for the world?
What can we do as people that
want to be a part of strengthening
the foundations of free and open source
software?
I think it's a whole different set
of strategies and tactics that we're able
to now start to think of and
to work at another level.
And yeah, I really think we've hit
this next whole phase where we spent
decades kind of maybe going through open
source 1.0 or something, and now we're
on to open source 2.0.
And that's not the original thing.
I can look to scholarly publications for
business schools that are saying that.
And there's citations about this and whole
discussions from well-established scholars right now that
are publishing using these ideas.
And that's different.
If you think about where I started
and me looking for things to cite,
what did I have?
I had Next to Nothing.
I had guru.org, some writings there, some
initial things from Eric S.
Raymond, The Cathedral and the Bazaar, which
was actually hard to apply, even though
there was some good ideas.
It didn't directly tie to like an
operating system that was in existence.
It applied conceptually of why we might
be able to have some arguments at
a business level, but how do you
point towards actual stuff and then make
the argument?
There was very little for me to
work with.
And now, nowadays, you can come at
it from sociologists who have published books
or gotten tenure from it.
You can come at it from anthropologists,
people like Chris Kelty, who did free
software and has gone on to sort
of free science and type work.
You can come at it from Yochai
Benkler and sort of a legal and
business school type approach and sort of
on and on across these different disciplines.
Often, they're multi-discipline kind of areas of
work that intersect between business and law
and technology, but they are their own
disciplines and they have their own conferences.
They don't even always feel tied to
using the language of free and open
source software.
They'll talk about open collaborative innovation projects,
is the term, right?
And the one strong example in their
papers is, well, free and open source
software is the best example.
This is the purest example of this
class of ways that people can encourage
user innovation or work with communities and
things like that.
But that's really exciting to me.
It's just a whole other set of
interested parties coming at it, valuing it
in their own ways.
To me, that is really important.
We don't have to position ourselves against
Eric S.
Raymond or Richard Solomon or Florence Lessig
or some of these other people.
We can value their contribution and we
can take the ideas, but we don't
ground everything in those anymore.
We have just a lot more happening
and a lot more people coming at
it.
That's important because we need to be
able to understand, we need to be
able to look at ourselves, look at
the work we're doing, look at issues
of sustainability, look at are we going
down a rut, are we blindsided, right?
Are we focusing on certain problems as
engineers, as collaborators, as people who want
to build these just because they're the
ones we've known how to do?
Or are we also looking to tackle
hard problems like climate change and other
things?
And I'm seeing a lot of people
that I grew up with in the
movement going from developing specific projects that
were standards to focusing all of that
and applying it to something like climate
change, like Evan Pradromo, who helped create
StatusNet and did a lot of early
federated social networking things.
The whole idea that we have mastered
on today, which is the distributed competitor
to Twitter, is because of having standards
that Evan was the chair of through
the W3C.
A lot of that work came out
of, I remember being at the Free
Software Foundation when the day before Liberty
Planet, the conference that I helped create,
they had a separate meeting and they
signed this Franklin Street statement on the
freedom of network services declaration and this
idea of moving towards federated.
But it was so entangled in issues
that so few people even could recognize
as mattering.
And now I can talk about it
in terms of, oh, people are mad
at Elon Musk for politics and things
that everybody, very large audiences understand.
And they're creating Bastidon and these tools
and that just be apps that people
have on there that don't take a
week to compile and install on your
laptop.
You just put it on your phone
and you can start migrating.
It's of real value and you immediately
understand it, where it was so theoretic
and so bogged out in technicalities and
hard to even, you can envision it,
but you couldn't talk about it like
you can today.
You can't give these real context.
And now we do.
And I think we're working at this
next level of, okay, what do we
do now?
How do we help continue to build
on this and take the good and
how do we get better at doing
it ourselves?
Wow.
That's the perfect way to end.
We are at time.
I don't know if you have one
more minute for one more question.
Yeah, yeah.
I have a few minutes to wrap
up here.
Okay.
It's a very general question, but I
think it applies.
If your great-great-grandchild were to stumble on
this recording 100 years from now, what
would you want them to know?
What would you say to them?
That 100 years ago, before where I
am now, there were engineers and visionaries
and artists coming together, solving hard problems
like electrifying the nation with electric lines
and building radio and they were having
geeky dinners through the Morse Society where
the whole dinner menu is in Morse
code and making jokes and all of
the types of support systems were necessary
back then that are here now, that
large numbers of people in those communities
were not neurotypical, that they had all
of the same challenges that people today,
100 years later, are having and are
able to bring together this idea that,
yes, there's engineering, yes, there's corporations, but
there's also important things that we're doing
for society, for humanity, for culture, for
institutions of education and that we're solving
a lot of these hard infrastructure and
institutional problems today and we face a
lot of the same social challenges and
the thing that worked back then and
that is also working now is not
forgetting that humanity of it, not forgetting...
Sorry.
Just to be there for each other
first and foremost and that's really the
thing that matters most and everything else
is about understanding if you have some
policies or laws or specific challenges, remember
that who we're doing this for are
people that we're doing it together to
make that your foundation and the thing
that your lens that you see everything
through is really that human lens and
if you do that, you'll have a
chance.
That's really beautiful, Josh.
Thank you.
Thank you for this interview.
It's been incredible and I hope we'll
be able to come back to you
and see what the next few years
brings.
You've got a lot of things left
to do.
Yeah.
Fortunately, I have a lot of people,
a lot of support.
It's really great.
Things like this project are amazing.
You're recognizing the individuals and the people
and getting the stories about how this
really works.
How did we actually do these things
and it's very raw and that matters
a lot to me and I really
appreciate the work you all are doing
and it's a pleasure to be a
part of.
It's an honor to be a part
of this, so thank you.
Thank you.